what's your takeaway from that well I
thought it was weak sauce Megan Kelly
yesterday went on Glenn Beck's radio
show and Glenn asked her about Trump's
answer related to whether men can become
women
what was your takeaway because he never
really answered it but he did shake his
head no towards the beginning can a man
become a woman
um
in my opinion
you have a man you have a woman I I
think I think part of it is birth can
the man give birth no no although
they'll come up with something what's
your take away from that well I thought
it was weak sauce I really wish he he
did better on that I like Ron desantis's
answer I'm going to be honest which is
no
no right no
no obviously no and it's not determined
based on who can give birth
determined by God and it's pretty
obvious just as soon as you come out of
the womb that's the way it's always been
that's the way it continues to be and
outwithstanding this weird agenda by
some activists in this crazy trans
agenda-pushing cult
um so Trump could really knows that I
don't know if he's got if he's trying to
like appease some group of trans voters
that he thinks is going to make the
difference with him even when I had Don
Jr on my show he was kind of dancing
around this issue I I think that they
think they're somehow gonna do better
with Democrats if they don't hit this
straight on even though I mean 98 of the
Republican party is United on this issue
this is not it is not a winner for any
Republican to hedge on this just ask ASA
Hutchinson
you know maybe Megan is right maybe what
Trump is kind of trying to do is he's
saying I've got the primary wrapped up
which by the way he does not and the
first votes are not cast in Iowa until
January but maybe in his mind he's like
so I'll start the pandering now Donald
Trump
he was sitting right in front of me I
would say it I would say Don Mr
President you know the difference
between a man and a woman and you know
that a man cannot become a woman but
maybe in his mind he's playing sort of a
cynical game he's saying I've already
wrapped this thing up so let me start
the pandering process right so I have to
move now to the center which by the way
all candidates on both sides do this you
run a certain way in a primary because
you're trying to get as many of your
people going and then you need that
crossover group but in this case this
trans thing is so out of control that if
Trump's calculation here is somehow I
will not cleanly and clearly State
whether a man can become a woman or not
so that maybe I can get some Democrats
to vote for me it's like do you want to
support that you have to think about
that but Megan and Glenn who by the way
uh well I can't swear that that Megan
voted for Trump do we know that for sure
she certainly has been very friendly to
Trump's ideas in the last couple years
Glenn absolutely voted for Trump last
time I voted for Trump last time but
Megan and Glenn are talking about this
and it's good because we need the full
pundit class to at least assess things
as honestly as possible